An organization that manipulates information and tries to monopolize the alliance etc. will find the current appraiser
Let's take a picture of
10 companies Don't say such things It's a
business meeting It's a joke 5 It's a
return for turning up the skirt Already
Sato
I wonder if something happened Day 3 is someone
attacking?
Maybe this is also a light one
Leave it to me
[music]
ani
yeah yeah yeah ran I can do it ran yeah Our job is security and thorough cleaning of the ground and preparation room after the competition
High level  There's no guarantee that someone will try to collect the DNA of a person with powers.In other words,
there have been many attempted incidents in the
past.In the midst of that, if you find a suspicious person, it's natural to hold a light guide
plate.In addition, a book.  I'm sorry I didn't care about it coming so hard
.